people are arrested in germany jailed
for speech no no
they are arrested they're arrested if
they use hateful speech because of
course
so you want nazis
you guys started it
time for the latest installment of
change my mind where we rationalize our
positions on controversial topics this
installment's premise is simple in that
while the media has been repeating ad
nauseam that president trump is a racist
well jesus christ of course he's racist
basically threatening us with going full
racist do you believe president trump is
a racist yeah
no question look at what he's done it's
racist
i'm not convinced i don't buy it but you
are welcome to change my mind including
you watching right now in the comments
section make your case and for those who
missed it this topic ruffled some
feathers before we even started
you're a damn backstabbing trump
supporter a goddamn lying ass
lying right to my face you want to sit
down and talk yeah i don't know you're
yelling i'm reasonable yeah i don't
scream at you
you [ __ ]
you straight from me jesus christ eat my
butt
click the link in the description to
watch the full video now once that
wrapped up we managed to have a couple
of people actually try and make their
case
well then why do you think that donald
trump is a racist you're like one of
those
is that a sentiment in finland
oh yeah
well that would be interesting to sit
down and talk about it because of
interesting more international approach
we just had uh this lady's from the
netherlands and she sat down
okay yeah come on let's do it
[Applause]
i'll kneel you can both sit and i'll
kneel are you sure yes it's totally fine
okay come on come on up come on up
just your friend yeah all right i have
to break the wilderness by myself
okay
so you're both finished we're both no
actually neither of us are finnish we
both live in finland oh where are you
from originally germany oh germany so
you're both german no she's estonian
well come on you're throwing me for a
loop are you finnish are you german are
you a stone i know
okay it's complicated we're expats so
german by way of finland estonian by way
of finland yes okay understood all right
i actually was raised in french canada
by way of united states now okay yeah i
had a good friend when i was being
raised to was finnish uh okay before we
continue because i know we'll get to the
donald trump thing let me ask you this
there's something really weird with my
friend who was finnish uh he would talk
to his mother when she was naked in the
bathroom oh yeah is that very common
yeah but that's very common in germany
as well okay it's not here i know i know
you guys have a weird thing about
nakedness well i'm more so naked moms
but yeah i remember i thought it was
really weird he was a great friend of
mine yeah yeah he didn't speak english
but we both spoke french and i remember
one time he was talking to his mom in
the bathroom i said what she was in the
bathroom he said yeah she was just
taking a bath i said but that's that's
exactly what i was insinuating you you
talk yeah i talk to my mom all the time
when she's in the bath so that's common
yeah it's common because we have sauna
so we love ourselves like getting naked
in front of others well i'm not gonna
lie that's a reason why i think the
united states is better
um all right so you were saying you're
from finland you said you don't
necessarily feel super informed but it
is a general sentiment in finland that
president donald trump is racist
i don't i don't think he's racist at all
but i would i i would love to hear why
you think that or why that's a sentiment
in finland changed my mind oh yeah sure
sure uh i think that's the sentiment in
finland based on his speeches you know
for instance about mexicans saying that
like you know
some of them are rapists and like you
know some of them are good people
yeah but um
yeah i think it's the general sentiment
in uh in finland is that he's racist and
like uh supports white supremacy
oftentimes even just about not saying
certain things you know like
not protesting certain things like when
we had the
uh charlottesville charlottesville
exactly yeah when he was talking about
like there's problems on like both sides
or like you know mistakes have been made
on both sides
yeah i find that very troubling because
it normalizes white supremacy so what if
i were to tell you that a lot of what
you just said would sort of indicate
media bias but the media is the one
lying to not really donald trump so take
the mexican thing for example where you
talked about rapists he was talking
about ms-13 it's a notorious uh south
american gang yeah yeah he never said
mexicans are rapists he was talking
about ms-13 and then said by contrast a
lot of mexicans are good people as it
relates to charlottesville you know i
don't do you know that he specifically
said in that same speech he specifically
said i'm not talking about white
supremacist or neo-nazis they should
they should be condemned totally but he
said that specifically
are you aware that he said that
no no
i don't think so would that change your
opinion on him not condemning them if he
said i'm not talking about white
nationalists i'm condemning them totally
he said but there were other people who
were not white nationalists on both
sides protesting and supporting the
robert e lee statue being torn down yeah
i know i know but uh in a way that kind
of for me normalizes because like we've
seen you know we've seen the kind of
people that were there and saying that
like they are not white supremacists
they are just like you know protesting
um which i think like if you protest
peacefully that's totally fine but that
was most people there
it wasn't all a white supremacist and
antifa protest there were there was
antiphon one side white supremacist but
there were a lot of locals at that
protest
just there over the robert e lee statue
and he did say there were fine people on
both sides they're protesting what they
saw as a very important statue coming
down he said now i'm not talking about
the white supremacists or the neo-nazis
they should be condemned totally yes yes
is that acceptable um no because it's
just a way of like you know it's a
it's a way of
doing his duty like he knows he's not
allowed to like he can't
completely
uh stand on the side of white
supremacists but in a way of not saying
certain uh certain things
[Music]
across the south support a certain
imagery what do you need to say like i
don't understand like for example for
example right now this guy right here
right i think he's very rude and i
appreciate you sitting down and i would
say hey listen today there were many
people here who were civil who were
polite on both sides meaning you more
liberal these people more conservative
and i would say i'm not talking about
that guy who is screaming and cussing he
should be condemned totally
am i supporting that guy i mean how much
more expressly could i condemn him
donald trump that's and i say this
because i genuinely don't understand how
someone can hear a president most people
don't know this when he says i'm not
talking about neo-nazis or white
supremacists they should be condemned
totally what language would satisfy you
no it's also about actions taken i mean
if i if i think about the fact that
somebody says like we need to like
on our border
like you have things like you know uh
what's wrong with that though what does
that have to do with white supremacy no
the absurdity is wrong
okay i'm from germany
and
what a wall generally means is either
you try people from getting out or you
like stop people from getting in right
and a little different though when
you're talking about the berlin wall
someone grows human rights tragedies
inside that wall that they wanted to
maintain the ability to
happening right now at the border where
like children are separated from their
families
well you know that's actually the
flora's consent policy that was you know
goes back to 97 and obama was the one
who was doing that first a lot of the
pictures you see your kids in cages that
was from barack obama so for the sake of
everything so the whole idea is that it
actually is considered inhumane to uh
separate uh to put kids in detention
centers
and so then people complain as they put
them in detention centers with their
families but i just don't think it's
genuine to compare the berlin wall
to protecting a border right i don't see
it i mean you mentioned white supremacy
this is interesting to me though because
i think a lot of americans right they
hear this and they watch it people who
watch the full take we go oh well he
says neo-nazis and white supremacists
should be condemned totally
clearly he condemns it and then you say
well it's not enough
and i i think that that's there's a
disconnect because a lot of americans
here everyone here
despises racism says well that's enough
for me he says they should be condemned
totally he's obviously not on board and
he repeatedly said that but you say it's
not enough so
it's got to be hard to convince people
that someone's a racist
is the liar you truly are yeah yeah well
that's because like i mean um
you know the way that we look at racism
is very subtle you know like there's
very like there are parts still in the
system that are very much like
race-based
you know that he reproduces
like yeah like why do you need a wall at
your border to protect your border to
keep illegal immigrants from coming into
the country
[Music]
okay who else how's that racist how who
else has a wall in
the world mexico
sure yeah a long time ago yes
the vatican
the vatican is that's a religious like
that's very very israel
that's once again a religious okay so
we're gonna throw out all the examples
of valid walls the point is we have a
problem though unlike
unlike germany we have a problem with so
many people want to get in our country
right
so many people wanted to come to germany
do you have any idea we have like one
year billionaire refugees we accepted
them all
yes okay
that was how's that working it has been
working out very well really there were
like huge like
okay maybe you haven't seen this but in
munich there were like refugees coming
from syria
right from like you know northern
in munich there were like people waiting
for them and they had like teddy bears
they had like presents for them and they
opened their
their hearts and their arms for them
because we know how hard it is if you're
going through a war you know
or if you're like in any way repressed
in your system like germany knows very
well what that's like right and having
like people
that take you with open arms is so
important in those moments and we let
them in like we had our border open like
angela merkel said they can all come
right
yeah they've changed it a little bit
since then because they've changed it
because they you've run out of room
yes yes
and the skyrocketing crime and the rape
and all that has been a real problem
there has no has been no skyrocketing in
crime and there hasn't been an increase
no there has been there has been a
drastic increase in rape and crime and
okay but then you are then you are
wrongly informed here because like
i worked in german media i worked in
german news
and that's not accurate it is accurate
there's been a drastic increase in rate
in germany
dramatically where do you have that
information from well you know i don't
have it at the ready but let's start
with cologne
you know you guys actually you guys have
actually gotten to the point of handing
out do not rape pants okay let's talk
about cologne but then let's talk about
what happens in dresden what happens in
saxonia where like
uh centers are getting burned down where
people are getting like screamed at when
they arrive right where like you have
like hate crimes we recently had a
politician getting killed because he
supported refugees yeah he got shot it's
terrible killed but that would also lend
itself to the overall increased crime
right in germany yes it hasn't been
super easy and that would lend itself to
the reason that said
we have a problem we need to cut down
but let me ask you this can someone can
someone oppose open borders and not be a
racist for example can someone support
strong immigration policy especially in
the most desirable country in the world
the united states uh i think you can
support strong immigration policy
um it's all about like the no i don't
think including a wall so if we support
a wall does that make someone racist
um
it's it it goes into a certain racist
narrative
um
that appeals to certain groups in the
society
i don't understand can you be more
specific um so if we talk about a wall
you know like why would we even need a
wall to stop illegal immigration because
more than half of illegal immigrants
enter the country illegally to the
mexican border sure but we already have
like you already we don't have i don't
live here but you have like a fence you
have parts that are a wall and that is
already like well no the problem is
working sometimes
we have many many many countless miles
of completely unprotected void right yes
yes and that's where the problems are
so again my question is that would be a
part that's not the only thing that
people support right but we do think we
have a problem right now of illegal
immigration in the country and we want
people to enter the country legally
clearly and she's from the netherlands
she was talking about her parents being
big american fans
my right here my mother migrated here
immigrated here legally right so the
people you hurt the most are legal
immigrants sister yeah so what about all
those legal immigrants you know black
white brown yellow uh who also support a
wall and stronger immigration policy
yeah right here oh just because you're
an immigrant doesn't mean you can't be
racist so they too would be racist i am
jesus christ my name is no like there's
of course like there's always the fine
line between like okay do i support like
stronger immigration laws uh you know
because i'm a conservative person or do
i support stronger immigration laws
because i am racist
yeah but if someone says for example
donald trump it's because they're
conservative and they have a problem
with illegal immigration as i do as she
does as donald trump does but you said
you think that that makes them racist
i'm curious
uh who's racist lying to yourself racism
i would go by the textbook definition of
sorry i racism he's very loud i
appreciate you and i having a good
conversation prejudice discrimination or
antagonism directed against someone of a
different race based on the belief that
one's own race is superior right so i
don't believe it's saying
something they believe that all members
of each race possess the characteristics
or abilities specific to that race
especially
distinguish it as inferior or superior
to another in other words believing that
members of your race are superior
this is a textbook definition
i don't see how in any scenario
wanting and this is just me being
ignorant because you know maybe everyone
here is a racist including the black
people and brown people who support
stronger borders i don't see how
supporting stronger borders and making
sure that people are migrating here
illegally is racist i don't see how in
any contemplation unless they said it's
because i don't like
mexicans because they're brown um
like if someone said that i would say of
course they're racist
well there's a very you know there's a
very fine line that is like kind of
getting like it's a tie drawing that
he's walking on i don't think so oh i
think i've seen plenty of evidence that
he's not racist i mean you look at the
diverse cabinet that he's appointed you
look at his praise of ben carson you
look at arsenio hall winning the
celebrity apprentice he's talked about
uh legal immigrants being great
americans and a great value to the
society
i don't see him walking a tightrope i
don't i don't see any evidence of him
being racist
because you mentioned charlottesville
and i would agree with you if he didn't
say
of course white supremacists and
neo-nazis should be condemned totally so
would we agree it seems to me maybe you
weren't fully aware that well we agree
that okay he clearly condemned them
let's move on from that let's say he did
a good job there right
and now you're saying he's walking a
tight rope well if he didn't what would
he need to do to satisfy do you remember
what he what would he need to say
outside of condemn them totally uh what
he would need to say to me is like you
know
these protests um you know are a way of
history repeating itself like going back
to times that honestly i don't want to
see in the us anymore
you know we're like people who are
liberal or you know like are getting
attacked like you have domestic
terrorism here which is white terrorism
yeah well it's not just white terrorism
but sure
this weekend it's why terrorists
okay let's go with white terrorism yeah
let's go with white terrorism i just
think it's terrorism because again they
didn't do it because they were white so
it seemed a little racist for you to say
that you just don't want to pay for it
no but like what i'm pointing at what
i'm one of them did it because he hated
immigrants and then the other one did it
because he was a socialist
environmentalist elizabeth warren who
wanted socialism in the united states
did you know that
by the dayton shooter that he was an
extremist socialist who killed
because he hates republicans
no no i didn't know that but um so i say
that because it's not like they all have
the same ideology right like islamic
terrorism if they're killing in a jihad
like isis we can say well that's islamic
terrorism right
white terrorism is not really they
weren't all white supremacists that's my
point but there's a person here who is a
white supremacist there was one person
there is a person here who is a white
supremacist full stop end of story that
is why terrorism that that one person if
you want to say it's islamic terrorism
then the other one is most definitely
white house like that's white
supremacist terrorism that one person
yes yes
yeah but i wouldn't say all homegrown
terrorists was white terrorism no i
didn't say that well you said you have a
problem here that's white terrorism yeah
i have a problem with white terrorism no
you said we have a problem that's white
terrorism and i was just saying there
was one white supremacist you have a
problem with white terrorism okay
and i'm not saying you don't have a
problem with other terrorism sure but
you have a problem with white terrorism
yeah terrorism is a problem in general
sure
all terrorism all terrorism is a problem
most definitely yes but why do you have
more white supremacist terrorism than
for instance we have in europe
we don't
can you just talk about someone trying
to kill the president or the mayor in
germany didn't you just talk about them
burning down refugee camps has that
happened in the united states ever
and that's what seemed to me to be white
supremacist terrorism right
anti-immigrant terrorism just listed me
a bunch of examples did you not just
that's far more extreme than we've had
here we had one person terrible but it
sounds to me like you listed multiple
incidents right
my point my only point is it happens
everywhere
we have refugees at the border is what
you were talking about we would just say
they're asylum seekers who will be
deported but my point is you know we do
you do have it in europe yes we do we do
have it you have white supremacy in
europe
yes of course of course particularly
germany
oh because it's a problem it's not good
anywhere i'm not defending white
terrorism yeah okay continue with your
point
before white terrorism we both agree
terrorism bad we both agree terrorism is
bad donald trump is racist because
okay donald donald trump is not racist
because
because there's no evidence that he's
been that he's a racist
if you make an outlandish accusation
that can destroy someone's life it is
your duty to prove his response to his
life are you [ __ ] kidding me accusing
anyone of racism is one of the worst
accusations you can love he's been
president for three years how has his
life come out a second i just answered
your question so i said he is not a
racist because i've seen no evidence of
him being raised argued what you said so
you no no i don't think he's a racist
because he's never done anything racist
he's done many things to the opposite
effect why do you think he's a racist
okay what has he done to the opposite
effect
i mean if you look at having ben carson
on his staff
i mean the guy is repeatedly
yeah embrace people of all different uh
colors as long as they uh have us line
up with the same political yeah he's the
token black person for the urban stuff
before he ran for president arsenio hall
one uh celebrity apprentice yes
typically not something a racist would
do
are you serious so is it his job to
prove to you that he's not a racist
because why really
you're a racist
you're a racist i'm not a
why would you not be a racist
why would i not be a racist yeah how are
you not a racist
how am i not a racist
i've never committed any racist crime
i've never used racist wording
ideologies
uh i've never asked for stronger border
control i've never
so you see asking i was with you with
everything because you were just like
donald trump until you said i never
asked for stronger border control you
think that makes someone racist
okay we just disagree um yeah because
like there's a rhetoric used here
uh downgrades mexicans as we know you're
buying as a race no
your problem isn't with uh donald trump
your problems with the law but the fact
that you assume all illegal immigrants
are brown mexicans tells me you're
racist
but the majority is though like we can't
ignore that that's pretty racist
no that's not racist at all that's just
factual i was talking about illegal
immigration you start talking about
brown mexicans
i didn't say brown
you use the word browns okay white
mexicans
okay
well dude like are you kidding me well
i'm just saying you said prove to me
he's not a racist prove to me you're not
a racist that's not how it works
if someone says
donald trump is a racist it is your job
to prove that he's a racist anyone's job
to prove that he's a racist i just don't
see it um what is the reason you need
stronger immigration
yeah several reasons uh for national
security reasons for economic reasons
what is the national security reason
give me that reason okay you have
unprotected borders and you have people
who are not being monitored who don't
pay taxes you have people who are
overstaying visas there is no way to
secure our borders if there is giant
unprotected swathes of our borders
what will a wall do so a wall it's not
just a wall
but a wall
obviously more cyber security more
guards on that wall and of course having
enhanced security measures that would
crack down and overstay visas
that would allow us to know who's in the
country
why are you the only country that needs
a wall
well because we have a huge border
that's unprotected and we have people
flooding through in record numbers over
a hundred thousand people a month oh you
think europe doesn't have a huge four
nine hundred thousand people a month a
hundred thousand people a month yes
honey like there's exactly like i
guarantee you not as many people
people coming from turkey like we have
you have immigrants sure yes we have
immigrants but you asked me a reason why
we would need a wall
and because you don't want a wall in
your home country you think americans
shouldn't want a wall in theirs yes we
have more people trying to get into this
country than any other country in the
world do you disagree
okay that's a fact let's just continue
more people are trying to get into this
country you have more people entering
germany with 80 million uh inhabitants
can handle one million refugees why
can't america with 300 million
inhabitants
handle three million refugees well you
just answered your own question
we have over 300 million people in this
country yeah and it's a problem it's an
economic problem and it's a national
security problem to have an economic
problem for people who aren't on the
books people aren't necessarily paying
taxes coming in and benefiting from
services here in the united states then
make them legal
well that doesn't help the problem
no that just encourages that just
encourages more people to enter the
country illegally and you end up with
them separated in refugee camps as you
put them because
they're encouraged there's no reason to
if you don't want people to be put in
canned border right if you don't want
people to be separated from their
families or kids to be locked up with
their families we need to stop the
ability for them to stop the incentive
for them to come here illegally
no we need to offer them asylum and we
need to offer them a way to legally what
if we don't want to no
why don't you want to what is your
reason that you do i want them to go
through the legal channels as all
no not if they're here illegally no
there is a legal way to come to this
country they're not doing it
i don't think that's racist
most americans don't think that's racist
your friend from the netherlands doesn't
think it's racist my french canadian mom
doesn't think it's racist that's okay
for my friend from the netherlands but
you think it's racist to believe that
people should enter the country legally
um i think it's racist to
believe
are that people that come from mexico
ultimately
[Music]
oh i have another beautiful example okay
what about calling
africa whole countries
we didn't say africa as a whole
countries you talk about multiple
countries
yes
how is that not racist
it depends on whether it's a whole
country or not
okay if i call like it's not that's not
saying that you believe you're superior
to someone because of the race i'm
saying you are
we are great i'm not gonna lie i think
germany is kind of a shitty country
doesn't mean i think germans are lesser
than americans i just don't like your
policies
well that is racist because you would
say that like germans are sh
no i think germany is a crappy country
for a multitude of reasons why is
germany a crappy country well you don't
have freedom of speech as one of them we
have
no you don't you don't have freedom of
speech you're not a freedom of speech
you jail people for unpopular speech you
jail people for offensive speech
yes you do no i don't know okay i'm not
going to argue with you
it is 100 accurate
you do not have freedom of speech
enshrined in the german constitution it
doesn't exist
let me continue on media i worked in
news media we have freedom of speech we
could write whatever we wanted to no you
don't no we do let me ask you this i
studied politics in germany i studied
the system what you're saying is a
planned
bland
lie no it's 100 accurate people are
arrested in germany jailed for speech no
no yes they're arrested they're arrested
if they use hateful speech because of
course
okay
off so you want nazis
you guys started it come on that's okay
let's not get heated any time we get
here we have to calm it down we if you
want to calm down no i'm sorry but this
is this is
stop we have nazis so people are
arrested for hate speech though people
are arrested for hate you don't have
freedom of speech so i think germany
city thank you
no i don't shake with you you're a liar
you're a [ __ ] liar i'm sorry but
where's the line i'm sorry where's the
[ __ ] line all speech is permissible
no line
all speech is permissible all speeches
are permissible no matter how offensive
it's permissible okay you can't jail
anyone for speech okay
so i mean you would be the one in the
1930-80s who would definitely vote for
hitler like yeah
no no no no no we voted for the guy who
beat your leader's ass
no you didn't you weren't alive i wasn't
alive you said if i were alive
okay okay seriously though but um if we
can't i mean i would vote i would vote
put it this way if i were in germany at
that time i would vote against the
national socialist who implemented gun
control and speech restrictions i would
vote against him
okay if i if i can say like
uh jews are bastards and i should all
die and i don't have to end up being
terrible to say yeah yeah it's terrible
and i don't like and you shouldn't be
jailed
you don't oh you don't always end up in
jail sometimes you just get a penalty oh
my god i don't think okay i don't think
you should be penalized for saying
something offensive
that's what i'm saying you don't have
freedom because i don't want that power
to be delegated to the government
because we never know who the next guy
is going to be the government should not
be in charge of who is allowed to speak
or what they're allowed to say okay okay
and if you think that makes me a racist
that's why i would never say this no i
understand that's liberal that's like
you have a liberal view on that i
understand that that's like i understand
and i think that countries that don't
support the united states is the only
country that has that i think it's here
so it's not because i hate germans but i
think that policy is a policy you may
disagree with me but you understand my
reasoning right you disagree with you
yeah okay but it's not because i'm
racist you understand right like i would
be right there saying hey that's a thing
to say if someone said that about jews
yes okay especially as a supporter of
israel i hate it when people go out and
just go and answer some of their thai
rights but
they have the right to do it
they have the right to do it yes in this
country not in germany
so there is no line for you not when it
comes to speech not when it comes to
speech okay so where is the line there
is no line with speech
so the line is in action
okay okay i understand that that's a
liberal view that's like
that's fine okay good yeah we've calmed
down now we're good yeah we've i think
you were misunderstanding me because you
think i was supporting race of speech
i'm not i just support people's right to
say it you're just twisting around words
no no i i'm trying to be as clear as
possible there is no lie i understand
you're liberal like i understand that
you're like liberal in that sense that
you say everybody should be able to say
whatever whenever right just like donald
trump
just like republica that's what
republicans conservatives tend to
believe freedom of speech is absolute
we're very liberal okay but then like we
will not like then you and me will not
find common ground because i believe in
the idea that discourse
and that what we are saying is shaping
our society i agree with you too that's
why i hope that you see this as
productive that's why we didn't just sit
and yell with him
but oh what happened
oh sorry
um i hope that you would see this
discourse as productive this is what i
try and do yeah yeah all i'm saying is
that
even though i think that guy's a jerk
and he was yelling and grading people
and screaming
i don't believe that i have the right to
shut him down to the government though
that's all i'm saying but this is the
discourse that i support and believe it
even if we disagree yeah like my problem
is that like basically if the discourse
is like filled with hate speech if the
discourse is filled with like
then it normalizes then it takes a step
to action like is a lot lower do you
know what i mean i i understand what
you're saying yeah but i think a far
greater risk is that step in giving the
authority to the government determining
what speech is permissible so i agree
with you if you say it's a slippery
slope right because we allow people to
speak freely and they might say
something that could inspire someone to
do something terrible and i agree that
could happen yes but i would say more of
a concern particularly as you mentioned
historically germany russia cuba these
places more of a concern is once the
government gets that power in
determining what is offensive what is
hate speech they expand that power and
that's a far greater risk than
individuals saying terrible things
that's just that's an opinion yeah
that's an opinion so you have a very
like i understand like you have a very
liberal like freedom-oriented
view
of government where i come from a very
social democratic system
where like we
we value certain ideals and certainly
like also security over freedom right
yes i understand that i don't disagree
with it
let's disagree with it yeah that i
understand okay all right well i think i
don't want to take i don't want to take
up the whole time but i appreciate
sitting down i hope we left it better
than when we got upset
okay
wow look at that we went from a one to a
ten in intensity and then back down to a
two thanks jesse by the way if you want
these segments to continue please
consider joining mug club at
loudouthcrider.com not only do you get
access to the full daily show not
available on youtube as well as this
hand etched girthy mug but it's the only
way for this content to continue on
youtube since the tech overlords have
deemed this series too controversial to
monetize or even be included in the
suggested feed okay on with the hate
speaking show
hello y'all all the way from california
oh thank you
what's your name
my name is
nice to meet you sorry i should have
said my name while shaking your hand
yeah
there's just so much going on here all
right so taisha right got that correct
if i get it wrong again i apologize um
this is pretty simple i mean you hear
this guy yelling
i'm not convinced that donald president
donald trump is a racist
i don't buy it
changed my mind i truly believe that
donald trump's a racist okay why because
donald trump don't understand the
difference between living
several lives you know saying some
people grow up growing up will with
silver silver and gold spoons in their
mouth and some people are not right
right and i really feel that he leaned
towards a sign that grew up with silver
and gold spoons in their mouth
right so my side is the side that didn't
grow up in that type of equality you
know i'm saying sure and i just think
that you know he's not for the people
you know saying he's selfish and he's
just for himself you're saying yeah but
at the end of the day i don't want to be
a part of the problem i want to be a
part of the solution you know saying so
i guess
we got to let him
serve his four-time for four years and
hoping he don't get elected for a second
term probably will huh probably will
then he probably will you know it's a 50
50 chance okay you know what i'm saying
i mean because at the end of the day my
vote is going to say that he would not
get a second term right walk agreed
donald trump don't need a second turn oh
well so maybe you gotta start some more
that's okay that's okay uh no i i
understand right now
exactly i wasn't raised with a silver
spoon but what specifically makes you
think that he's a racist because that's
a very that's a very lofty accusation
right to toss out there
well you know i mean at the end of the
day you know i grew up around hispanic
people you know and i love the hispanic
people and i understand i mean he has a
great argument about putting the wall up
at the end of the day but i don't like
the simple fact that he separated the
children from their parents you know
saying i mean
i'm a child development major of course
and of course it says that a child needs
to be with someone that cared for them
and not with strangers you know what i'm
saying right i mean i believe in
children being around either the mom or
dad or someone that they know right
don't say anything
it was i remember it was one situation
where he separated he completely
separated the mom from the child for at
least six months and i believe the child
was not even 10 years old right you know
what i'm saying now and you you believe
that makes him a racist yes okay yes
i mean would he want his son separate
with him no i don't think anybody would
no do you believe barack obama's a
racist
um not really i mean but barack obama
was for everybody but he did that huh he
did that i don't remember him separating
no change bill clinton it goes actually
back to the 97 floors consent policy
where they said that you can't separate
children from their parents right it was
a problem and so then they stopped doing
it because they saw it um basically as
cruelty for children to be separated and
then they ended up putting them together
which is how you see these families and
what they refer to as children in cages
which actually the pictures you saw
happened under barack obama but he did
that exact same thing right and as a
matter of fact barack obama deported
more illegal immigrants than donald
trump up to 400 000 a month donald trump
stayed under 300 propaganda right so but
at the end of the day
but at the end of the day trump is still
in his first term barack obama already
served
two
i'm pretty sure his his numbers were out
you know our number um
well no i'm talking about on a month on
an annual basis or a month-to-month
basis so i'm not saying totality
obviously barack obama wouldn't deport
more i'm talking about a consistent sort
of on a per
series her period of time basis my only
question for you is you know i don't i
don't think barack obama is a racist i
don't think bill clinton's racist i
don't think donald trump's a racist i
don't think george w bush was a racist
but if barack obama and bill clinton did
the exact same thing
you believe that they are racist because
that was what you said right justified
and also also like i said i mean barack
obama okay when you speak on barack
obama barack obama was for all races
right but he did the same thing as first
celebrating families okay absolutely
okay i totally agreed that he separated
families and all that but at the end of
the day
but at the end of the day let me tell
you barack obama is for all walks of
life trump is not you know i'm saying
he's ready to come in there and cut this
cut that cut this cut that stuff that
people actually rely on you know saying
i mean he's not saying well within five
years he's not even pre-warning people
and said within five years of cutting it
within 10 years i'm cutting this i think
it's only fair if you see poor people
you need to pre-warn them so they can
make changes in their life and get
prepared for things to be cut
right so you are saying
i just want to make sure i understand
this you said because he separated
families that was racist
but it's not racist for barack obama to
do it because you believe that in
combination with the fact that trump is
not for everyone you believe he's racist
at the end of the day i think everybody
have racism
and i don't care who you are you have
racism so not donald trump particularly
more than that say like you're you're
walking i mean you say like you're
driving down the street you get caught
you're like your mom somebody out their
name what they really mean
race yeah
something like that
yeah about i get it nothing but
personally i hope you don't get a second
term i just don't hope that right but i
do think it's important i mean because
accusing somebody of racism right that
can be something that alters people's
lives you know if someone isn't a racist
they're called a racist right they can't
get a job right right they're [ __ ] and
feather for the rest of their life
donald trump isn't for all people
um i mean i don't agree black americans
have it better under donald trump
actually
black people answered saying they don't
think that life was better for black
americans
but these are polls from gallup and
rasmussen and black unemployment is on
an all-time low you are a racer so it
seems to me that he's doing some things
that are benefiting everybody
exchange people who were in the middle
class they didn't they didn't uh qualify
for the benefits and so they were harmed
right so what donald trump is trying to
do and i agree he hasn't enough on
health care but he's trying to fix it in
a different way so i think here's what i
would ask do you think that maybe just
maybe i appreciate how civil this is
compared to that guy streaming and
yelling just hold on thanks um that
maybe you have a preconceived notion
about president trump and so you sort of
attribute racism there where it may not
be
you maybe have some prejudice do you
think that could be fair to say i'm not
no i'm not president i wouldn't say i'm
precious i'm absolutely not prejudiced i
didn't deal with all walks of life all
races i didn't work around no i mean
donald trump donald trump prejudice
against donald trump because you seem to
you've seen to sort of presuppose that
he's a racist before he analyzes action
i just personally don't like the guy
because of the simple fact of you know
how could you elect a president that got
away with so much you know i'm saying i
mean yeah he don't even like women y'all
saying i mean i think he likes women a
lot no not not what simple packages oh
he grabs him by the crouch and all of
that i think he likes him you might like
him a little too much
nah but that's disrespectful
it's disrespectful yeah if you're you
and your wife was walking down a truck
right here i'm pretty sure you wouldn't
want to knock him out oh yeah of course
i thought you were saying he was gay no
i wasn't saying he was gay no no saying
that how could you elect someone that's
under these circumstances of what they
did
whether if they pass their press or
whatever yeah no
i'm not here to defend everything from
donald trump i just don't see any
evidence that donald trump is a racist i
see a lot of evidence of the contrary
and that you see him keeping praise on
all kinds of black americans he was the
first uh he was the first uh president
to release that i forgot her name the
black woman who was in there for drug
related crimes he commuted her sentence
she was out okay right barack obama
never did it actually i think i might
have her uh i'll find him on that it
wasn't anita it was what was the name
darren the lady who he commuted her
sentence black lady drug-related crimes
well maybe he liked someone remember
that if someone had google really
quickly the black lady for uh donald
trump commuted her sentence for
drug-related crimes it wasn't anita it
wasn't it was an a though allison
alice alice
alice marie johnson so he did that and
talked about what a great woman she was
i mean my point yeah maybe with some
black people right but the point is i
don't think we've seen him do anything
that would indicate he hates black
people but he could have done that um
because he don't want people to believe
that he races he could have been
something like that like
if you assume he's racist though see
you're saying because you don't but
you're assuming that he is racist what
if he's not i'm never going to be
convinced that he's not well that's not
fair
it's not fair to say that though
shouldn't shouldn't you have to prove
that someone's racist
yeah you
mean i've been accused of being a racist
just because i believe that we should
have border security right i mean
where's
i think we should have border security
too he's biracial he works for me right
now
yeah you know my point is i'm not saying
that's hey my token black friend but the
point is
it doesn't mean that you hate black
people just because someone says let me
let me read you a couple of quotes i
want to see if you think that these
these are racist okay and the reason is
just because i do this is an exercise
it's not a gotcha
well i don't want to tell you first okay
let's read these as donald trump groups
i want to i know you didn't look that up
to wikipedia no no these are real quotes
i promise you okay
all right so hold on a second let me
find this here really quickly
because i know in college we're talking
to uh give someone credit if you're you
know yeah yeah i'll give you a group
credit afterward but i want to see
because i this is a mental exercise i
think you're attributing a little bit
more racism than is actually there
and we've all done it if it's someone we
don't like remind you right i'm not
gonna lie to you like
i wasn't a huge fan of barack obama i
come from quebec socialist province so i
might have had some blind spots where i
attributed motive in my mind where i
shouldn't have so i'll admit that all
right so let me ask you this do you take
this as a racist quote
uh legal immigrants enrich our nation
and strengthen our society in countless
ways i want people to come into our
country in the largest numbers ever but
they do have to come in legally
is that racist
that's not racist okay he's just saying
that he don't want to cut it illegally
he's not gonna come in illegally okay
okay uh america proudly welcomes
millions of lawful immigrants who enrich
our society and contribute to our nation
but all americans are hurt by
uncontrolled illegal immigration
not always true
okay but you wouldn't say that's racist
uh yeah it sounds racist because we're
not always hurt by illegal immigrants
but all americans are hurt not always
hurt but all americans are hurt
all right what about this maybe as far
as taking away our resources okay so
maybe all right i'm reading these in
progressive order right
the american people who are a welcoming
and american people are welcoming and
generous people but those who enter our
country illegally and those who employ
them disrespect the rule of law and
because we live in an age where
terrorists are challenging our borders
we cannot allow people to foreign the
united states undetected undocumented
and unchecked americans are right to
demand better border security and better
enforcement of immigration laws does
that sound racist
that don't sound right
good we are a nation of laws
undocumented workers broke our
immigration laws and i believe that they
must be held accountable especially
those who may be dangerous
that's why over the past six different
criminals
uh so you think this is racist this one
no it's not racist because it's only
pretending to be immigrants you know
right my question was
donald trump and barack obama are very
similar immigration policy okay but you
know i know the difference between
somebody being racist and somebody's not
being racist right so what do you what
would be an example of donald trump
being explicitly racist you don't
understand you're talking with somebody
that he makes and all that stuff i mean
but if you engage
because everybody goes on hard times
is
well that's fine that was that was
productive i think we both discussed
that and figured it out but i just still
don't think he's a good president to be
you know
that's fine
i understand because you need somebody
you need somebody to understand all
walks of life you're saying you need
somebody to help our country not hurt
our country but our country's doing
better than ever before at the end of
the day we do have record low
unemployment we have higher wages you
know we have more we have a job surplus
there are more jobs available than ever
before
um our country is doing really well so
everyone is doing really well there's
more class mobility now it's never
perfect but i would say that that is
indicative of someone who's trying to
improve the country for everyone but you
know we can disagree on that but okay
but when you start cutting stuff
from the poorer people
it's more hard because why they're going
to start talking to people that have
more whether they work for it or they
got it with how they got it you'll see
it you know i think an antidote to more
crime is more employment we have more
employment than ever before so i know
that's why
that's not always what about the people
that don't want to work those
what about people
who don't want to work totally yeah i
have no talent
what about the people that relies on the
government and all that stuff and then
if he cut that cut it
no why would you people who don't want
to work cut it what do you mean cut it
cut that i don't i wouldn't want to cut
it why because anybody can follow a hard
time somebody can lose a job for you you
don't want to work okay
welfare with recipients cut it
okay but at the end of the day and i
don't think that's crazy
hard time because everybody falls on her
fall in hard times but that's very
different that's
much easier to measure than people who
don't want to work right so you know
when you look at like for example the uh
the green new dealer look at some of the
proposals from cortez
you
i don't want nobody to be breaking in my
house
well if you're affording a brand new car
because you're working that's a good
thing but i don't think that i don't i
don't wanna have a gun at my head and be
held hostage by someone who doesn't
wanna work saying hey give me this free
stuff otherwise i'm gonna commit crime
that's not how it works no well you
don't get you don't get free stuff and
if you commit crime we lock you up right
right but guess what somebody might have
to get hurt or die before that person
get locked up well they'll just lock
them up i think it'll i think it's it's
a better solution than giving people
free stuff because we're afraid they
might loot and cause problems i don't
believe that's how i understand where
you're coming from but i don't
necessarily agree right i understand
you'll fall in hard times but people who
don't want to work they shouldn't they
would think
between a man and a woman because yeah
um
oh man that's tough god's been a college
student oh good for you
awesome thank you
hey if you enjoyed this installment of
change my mind click one of these other
installments in the videos playing in
boxes here that's the only way you'll
find them because if you search change
my mind they might not show up
because youtube's deemed them
controversial subscribe hit the
notification bell and you know we'll
we'll see you but we probably won't